is taking a foul committed by batum
it is 6.4
[Applause]
and beasley will be at the line
[Applause]
it was a playoff atmosphere in this
play-in game
and russell
was at his best he had one point russell
had one point in the first quarter he
had 28
over the next three quarters of the game
well we talked about him being the x
factor right and
if there ever was a game that he needed
to step up with carl anthony towns going
three of 11 11 points and fouling out
it was tonight
easily at the stripe
beverly with some instructions for his
team and a five-point lead with 6.4 to
go
listen and picked up by beverly and
that's all she wrote the timberwolves
are going to the playoffs
[Applause]
timberwolves
in the playoffs for just the second time
since 2004.
they went in 2018 with jimmy butler
and they're going in 2022 led by patrick
beverly who has become in his first year
the most impactful player and truly the
heart and soul
as he hugs his former teammates where he
played for four years and reggie it's
clear to say for him it was personal
tonight well it was personal but it
shows you
the clippers giving him hug how much he
still has respect
in that locker room for the clippers but
this has to feel good for him now the
clippers will get another swipe at it
another chance
friday at home
against the winner of new orleans in san
antonio we'll finish up that in a second
out to the floor and ali laforce well
d'angelo congratulations on the win as
you watch your team celebrate in front
of this incredible home crowd so a
little under two minutes to go you hit
the bucket that gave the team the
biggest lead of the game i watched you
sit on that bike and tell this team no
matter what foul trouble they got in
it's okay we got this what gave you the
confidence can you be so calm out there
we special we got a special group
it could be anybody's night like i've
been saying all season
today we we locked into the to the
details and what it was going to take to
beat that team which is a team's
unbelievable a good team well coach got
a great group of guys
but our group is resilient i think
everybody on tv it's our first tv game
all year
everybody on tv should see what's going
on behind me it's hard for me to talk
but
our fans are amazing and this is so
special it is truly amazing and we will
show that your team led the league in
scoring all season but you did that with
carl anthony towns on the court and
tonight you had to do it without him
first of all after the game when you
hugged him what'd you tell him and how
did you guys overcome it
i mean that's our guy that's our guy
it's our all-star he's been holding it
down for us all season
tonight their game plan was to take them
out the game and we had to respond as a
group
in our group i wouldn't take any other
group other than ours we got 12 15 guys
that can show up any night and dominate
so we're committed to that and this is
the second playoff win for this
franchise since 2004. are you able to
put into words what it means to not only
the team with this city not excited not
excited i think we're supposed to be
here
the nba put a play in situation in for
teams to get in
we're not excited i think we're supposed
to be here we're supposed to take care
of business tonight we're supposed to go
take care of business in phoenix so i'm
in uh in memphis so same same thing
congrats on the win enjoy it thank you
uncle had 29 points tonight he was the
second overall pick and he was sick
selected by the lakers then traded to
brooklyn then golden state
and coming to minnesota and in
this season and in the biggest game for
him he has answered the bell along with
the rest of the team and kevin this is
why team sports are beautiful when
you've got a band of brothers and he
highlighted that our best player you're
right our captain our all-star struggled
tonight and a band of brothers
came together and found a way
to win and move on
and officially in the playoffs to go
against the number two seeded memphis
grizzlies you don't think this game
meant something to former clipper
patrick beverly at 33 years of age oh
man the tears of joy
and the emotion pouring out
as he knew when he came here he'd become
the heart and soul in carl anthony towns
even when he was off